le polar net dans les cales de ce cargo
turc 12000 tonnes de maïs ukrainien qui
était attendu comme ce navire d'autres
sont partis pour le liban l'italie de la
turquie ces derniers jours conséquence
de l'accord trouvé le mois dernier entre
la russie l'ukraine la turquie et l'onu
la réouverture des ports ukrainiens sur
la mer noire et l'autorisation des
exportations agricoles russe de quoi
éloigner le risque de pénurie mondiale
de céréales après plusieurs mois de
conflit en ukraine et un trafic paralysé
nous avons réussi à relancer les
exportations maritime dufregne n de
produits agricoles l'eau port fonctionne
à reichshoffen si nos partenaires
remplissent leurs obligations et
garantisse la sécurité d en voir esprit
cela va vraiment résoudre la crise
alimentaire mondiale
un espoir partagé par l'organisation des
nations unies pour l'alimentation et
l'agriculture la fao
le les marchés répondent aux prévisions
il répond très rapidement le jour même
où l'accord a été annoncé les prévisions
sur les prix ont commencé à baisser
pour la fao l'effet de l'accord se fait
déjà sentir au niveau mondial selon ses
calculs les indices de référence des
prix alimentaires mondiaux a baissé
entre juin et juillet passant de 154 3
points à 140,9 en plus de la reprise du
trafic sur la mer noire les
transporteurs ont trouvé d'autres voies
d'export comme ici sur le danube où des
centaines de camions attente de pouvoir
décharger leur cargaison dans les ports
fluviaux ukrainien et moldaves tout ne
s'annonce pas rose pour autant de
nombreux experts relativisent faibles
perspectives de croissance fertilisants
de plus en plus cher et catastrophes
climatiques de nombreuses incertitudes
pèsent encore sur l'agriculture mondiale